those fidelity or somebody did a study
that basically said out of all of our
portfolios who's got the best performing
portfolios and it's people who lost
their password or died right it's just
kind of once they put it on they didn't
touch it and some of the basic mistakes
I know that you guys have talked a lot
about you mentioned the high fees but
also one that I find really fascinating
is kind of this home country bias maybe
talk a little bit about how you guys
think about that and kind of why is that
so prevalent especially here in the
United States where things have gone
pretty well over the last you know
decades and people tend to kind of think
us centric rather than as cool plus they
should so the 2010s
were 20 teens were an exceptional decade
to own u.s. assets go full rip van
winkle in 2009 wake up in 2019 god bless
you that's all you had to do for the
entire decade and the problem with most
investors their myopic they extrapolate
that infinity to to you know as far as
you could see going back to what Mark
said earlier they destroyed everything
else and we we did another poll on
Twitter I love to source polls on
Twitter and I said you know by the way
people what has been the best performing
asset the last 20 years and I think it
was like stock US stocks real estate
gold something else bonds maybe and
everyone said stocks but in reality
stocks US stocks were the worst because
the to thousands were terrible for US
stocks but that's the way it works one
Rosine regime sets the stage for the
next emerging markets dominated the
early 2000 small cap value everything
else just crush US stocks and then the
20 teens US stocks did great and these
things play out over the periods of not
just years but but decades as well the
problem is then people say okay US
stocks forever
and traditionally markets that go up if
you look at the p/e it's the pea that's
going up so markets that go up a ton
usually get more expensive and what
we're seeing right now is it markets
that go down a lot it's it's you know
they're getting cheaper for a reason
and but it's the pea it's the price
going down but people extrapolate that
so the problem is Vanguard is done a
bunch of studies here we have as many
others people for some unknown reason
and there's a known reason I can I can
understand
but they put the vast majority of their
assets in their own market so US
investors of their stock portfolio on
average put 80 percent in the US now
that's not as awful as you think it is
because the u.s. is around half of the
world stock market cap but in other
countries this happens in every country
around the world Spain Italy UK Japan
all struck every single country does it
and in some of the countries that are
only like 3% of world market cap Canada
etc it's a really horrible mistake
because you're making a massive massive
overweight people say look I feel
comfortable I understand these companies
but it's really a false sense of
security and so we did a post on the
blog and summarized it at the end of the
year where I took my six favorite
research pieces on global investing last
year one of them was from Bridgewater
and they said look US stocks
outperforming in global equal weight is
an anomaly in fact it's only happened a
couple times in the past twelve decades
it happened the 2010s it happened in the
90s before that you had to go back to
1920 and so and there's been a bunch of
studies on there that show that
diversifying of buying the global market
cap you end up with lower volatility and
you eliminate the outlier outcomes we
talked earlier you eliminate the South
Africa being the best but also Austria
being worse so you get somewhere better
than in the middle because you get a
diversification benefit and it really
makes no sense to just look at one
country and let me elaborate on that for
a little bit more on on as to why so
that's that's one mistake of just doing
it and you ask anyone in the world right
now who's living in Russia Greece Brazil
about putting 80 90 percent in your own
market and they say that was the dumbest
thing I've ever done in my life because
it's now down 60 70 80 90 percent it's
also compounded but if you look if you
go back to 1970s and there was a neutron
bomb that went off in the asset
management industry and most people
think that it was indexing which was a
massive massive invention you know
bogel Vanguard has become very famous
for doing it they manage over what four
trillion now others were doing at Wells
Fargo etc on down and they came up with
this idea that if you just bought the
entire market you could do it it's super
low cost because you literally didn't do
anything
you just bought stocks according to
their side and the funny part is if you
ask people a lot of investors don't know
this you say what is like say a market
cap weighted US stock fund how is it
weighted and people say buy stocks
you know you buy the biggest stocks and
that's correct but most people usually
think it's by revenue cash flow earnings
and that's not true
it's actually the only variable in stock
price some shares outstanding that's it
there's no tether to value whatsoever so
if if a I know you love aliens if you're
an alien and you came down he said is
that a reasonable way to invest does
that make any sense you kind of scratch
your head say why would anyone invest
like that you would never buy a business
like that you would never buy a lemonade
stand with no reference value or a house
or a car anything else why would you
that with stocks now the reason it
actually works is because in the stock
market people understand this when it
comes to private investment it's but it
happens in the stock market too
all of your returns are determined by
the outliers so there's about 5% of
stocks in the entire stock market that
determine your entire return it's
holding the amazons the McDonald's the
Walmart's the apples of the world that
have these multi baggers up ten times up
a hundred times up a thousand times to
generate all the returns so by indexing
by owning everything you are guaranteed
to own the big winners that the power
laws of investing is if you look at the
distribution about two-thirds of stocks
underperform a broad index almost half
over the lifetime of the zero rate of
return and around a quarter probably now
a third are trade up zeros over their
lifetime which is why stock picking is
so hard just by throwing darts you're
probably not going to get a winner but
people are attracted to it just like
catnip because they see the outliers and
say oh my god if I put 10 grand and
Berkshire Hathaway in the 60s out of 200
million dollars today so anyway that's
that's
the base case market cap weighted
investing and that's good but it's
pretty suboptimal and the reason being
is that there's really free markets and
capitalism and it makes sense where if
you invest in Apple and it gets the size
where it's a trillion dollar company you
better bet that someone in Korea or in
Europe wants to make billions of dollars
too and so you have that creative
destruction you have the competition
where other companies come in and
there's been a lot of quant Studies on
this research affiliates has done it if
you look at the largest stock in the
stock market so by market cap weighting
it under performs the broad market by
three percentage points per year for the
next decade this applies to every
country this applies to every sector and
it should make sense and it does make
sense because it's really the price
going up with no tether to fundamentals
so you can create an investing strategy
it doesn't matter what it is it could be
equal weighting it could be waiting
based on value which we like momentum
whatever it is it could be waiting based
on whether a CEO wears bow ties or
regular ties are no ties all of those
should be market cap weighting by about
a percent or two per year now why is
this go back to the home country bias
discussion and comment well it also
applies to the global portfolio and so
we said overweight in the US isn't a big
of a deal because the u.s. is is 50
percent versus 80 which is what people
in but the US came into 2020 being one
of the most expensive countries in the
world which half happens all the time
with market cap weighting so we just
demonstrated why it happens on
individual stocks but it happens to
entire markets too and so if you look
back in history the big the big
granddaddy of them all we like to use
long term valuations called Cape ratios
which is a ten-year price to earnings
but you can use anything you could use
dividends sales cash flow whatever in
the 1980s Japan so for reference long
term P ratios are around 18 you've seen
countries get as low as five the u.s.
hit 45 and 90
but Japan had almost hundred it was the
largest market cap country in the world
in the eighties you're probably too
young for this but every magazine
article every TV story every book was
about the Japanese business model is
about how they're outperforming
everything in the world we all had to
copy Japan and it turned out is just the
biggest bubble we've ever seen but if
you were market cap weighted investor
you put most of your money in the
biggest bubble we've ever seen when it
was the most expensive and so this is
something that happens over and over
again
happened in the US are happening
globally with the u.s. you know at the
end of last year and so it's the good
news is a pretty easy problem to fix you
diversify you try to wait with the tilt
towards value or any other metric but in
general the problem with putting it all
your eggs in one basket particularly a
home country bias is you end up saddle
to a very specific outcome and you ask
most people around the world and they
would say it's it's usually not a good
one